你以為的超底是一個Nike
但是真實的情況是如何呢
喔喔
勝率最高
最最高的超底的型態
我今天給你一個很棒的型態
來看一下
這個叫頭尖底
只要沒有跌破1.2
都是一個好建造
而且這個回測再長
這個勝率
機率大概就乎90%了
我巴不得找到一個
無敵超級巨大頭
可是它的價差會更大
目標價也會更大
其實加碼有一定的地方
這個就可以這樣
那這一根是不是突破了
對
那離突而又長
這個幅度很大
100長到140
每一集都讓大家都想買
大家都想買
看你台單就每一集都想買
朱老師
美鳥那我們現在十年後再結合
好像威力更強大
強強
因為好像有人在捷運上
在路上看到你都還認得出你
對 所以我們現在外面不可以亂來
要特別小心
而且是看我們理財打安秀對不對
對 現在看造華這個節目的人非常多
但是也因為朱老師
我們也加入很多新的粉絲
是
這時候我就有點傲腦了
因為我10年前就有去上你的課
就在台北車站那附近
一堂課200塊而已
對啊
那你後來都自己跑掉了
都不忘光了
我交了十年
你交十年
我都沒有再去
因為後來我專題做完了
我就沒有再去了
對
因為你要忙你的
所以像我這樣就錯誤的學習
忙你的事業
如果我十年前跟你學的話
我覺得就很多股票可以買在底部
對
股票最難就是能夠在底部找到
而且大家都很羨慕做長線
每個都說
長線可以賺好幾倍
那你長線一定要底部做
對啊
都走到頭上一直不做長線
我常常去追長啊
對 所以我們要學會在底部找底部
對 但是很多人又喜歡去抄底
認為疊身的就是底
其實不是
底還有更低喔
底要成型才行
底如果還要破底的話
就永遠沒有底
所以我上課有一句名言
我相信同學都聽過了
股價沒有高低的
股價沒有高低
只有多空
他如果是空永遠都一直破題
所以他一定要打出一個底部型態
好 今天這堂課重要啦
因為大家會想說
要是大家像10年前像我一樣
就認識朱老師
那不得了囉
很多股票高保你就可以買在底部
但是朱老師剛剛講了
他的名言有沒有聽到
股票沒有高低只有多空
永遠永遠都有在底部
等著旗長的股票
隨時都有
所以重點是什麼
重點是底部的型態
你到底學會了沒有
那本節目非常佛心
因為底部的型態
可能有幾十重
但是絕對會教你
勝率最高最最高的底部型態
所以今天這堂課教你超底喔
好
我們這邊先來看一下
散戶的新生
你以為的超底是一個Nike
你以為超底是個Nike
嘿嘿 我在這邊買就對了
他都跌這麼多了
我在這邊買
買了就會長
就是一個 Nike 的符號啦
但是真實的情況是如何呢
剛朱老師講的
其實骨架不要看到疊身就是低
低 還有更低
還要更低 為什麼放髒話
製作人的心腸不太好
所以真實的情況是我們常常
越摸越低
所以我們常常講不要去超低啦
不要去超低
可是我找你來就是要超低啊
大家口袋沒那麼深啦
一直超不完的
其實也很簡單
我們在前面那麼多集了
我相信這些觀眾看到
都應該有概念了
你超底是要做多還做空
做多啊
做多嘛
做多你怎麼可能買到最低點
你來我就有可能啊
不可能啊
大家要有一個概念
我們一般散戶永遠買不到最低點
其實我們上一集有經常一個東西
N字底
N字底也不是買在最低點
也不在最低點
也在第二支腳嘛
第二次交
那因為你一直都是底底底
所以一直都是空頭
所以你不可能
摸到最低
那我們做為了一個保險
你至少要出現一個形態
你才可以考慮這邊開始做
好不好
什麼形態
今天超底的形態
我今天給你一個很棒的形態
我們來看一下
這個叫頭肩底
上次是n字底
這是叫頭肩底
還蠻常聽到的
為什麼這個很好
各位看目標成功率八成以上
等一下老師
83%怎麼算出來的
這是統計的
比如說他統計了1000張
有800多張都到了
都會到目標
所以這是統計的
這個底完成了
他還會有一個回測
換句話說你來不及上車
你還有一個回測以後的機會
也就是說兩張有兩檔股票
有一檔會回測
那當然另外一檔就直接到了
了解
就不回來了
所以我們大概知道他的勝率
因為我們超底要超勝率高的
上禮拜的N字底也是勝率很高
這禮拜的投奸底勝率很高
那我們要抓投奸底
先要有幾個認知
認識投奸底要三星吧
底部反轉做多的機會
出現的就意味這邊大概就是底了
如果你看到投奸底這邊大概就是底了
那這樣子你比剛才亂去拆底要好多
第二個它有一個很明確的V型反轉
對 它中間有一個V型反轉
再加上有大量長紅 所以突破
所以成功率很高
那目標價所有的型態都有目標價
只是算法不一樣而已
上次N字底有教我們算
對 有一個正波段的預算方法
預測方法
那我們投間底也會有一個目標價
但是目標價我們在上級也講
沒有說百分之百都會到
所以他剛剛說百分之八十幾嘛
對不對 並沒有百分之百會到
所以你在操作的時候請按照紀律
還是按紀律
你按五均就五均十均就十均
五均十均都可以
好 所以投間底到底長什麼樣子
就像這個樣子
他有三個很重要的給你觀察的
第一個我們剛剛講
這裡有個V型反轉
那什麼叫V型反轉
就是集諜集長
是
當然這個幅度會比較大
因為你幅度大以後的目標價
才會比較大
如果你這個頭尖底小小的
那個目標下就很小
所以要大頭
對
頭越低越好
因為造法也是大頭
所以我喜歡大頭
大頭都比較聰明
那還有兩個特徵
就是左邊有一個低點
右邊有一個低點
所以這個叫左肩
這個叫右肩
那這個左肩跟右肩都有很
很嚴格的標準
他現在是大頭小肩膀
對 等一下我們都會詳細的講
形態大概長這個樣子
大頭小肩膀
但是有更嚴苛的
可能用數據化的標準
那我們來看一下
我問一下趙華
這兩個看起來都是頭肩體
都像剛才我們畫的對不對
所以有個V字
可是這兩個的位置不一樣
所以你覺得哪一個比較好
我覺得如果是超底
當然是這個 它跌下來啦
這看起來像上去公不上的感覺
這已經漲過一波了
所以這在高檔
也就是多頭已經走到頭上
那這個是空頭
這個地方跌下來是空頭
然後它只是空頭做了一個反彈
反彈然後再做這邊右肩
因為這個價位已經太高了
所以這個就不叫超底了
好 所以股價的位置很重要
如果那張圖
他常常出現在股價比較已經漲過了
他不能叫投奸底
對 他又不叫超底了
所以這是標準的投奸底
標準投奸底
就是你左邊一定是從上面一直跌
跌到最低點
然後在這裡打底的
這個當然他就是一個很好的投奸底
但是剛剛老師講了
不是漲這樣就叫投奸底
他有一個數據標準
對
那投奸底
我剛才有講
最重要是在這個地方
它的左肩跟右肩
要在這個微型反轉的
1 2 分之 1 的上面
喔 好 好 好
大家看一下囉
這個地方微型反轉
你畫個 1 2 分之 1
要在 1 2 分之 1 的上面
如果它變成一個
很下面三個一樣大就不行
那就 W 底了
那就是 W 底
或者 3 重底了
如果這個太低了
就變 3 重底了
就變 W 底了
所以我們上禮拜的 N 字底
是不是一樣
也是 1 2 分之 1 的地方
對
第二隻腳不能超過 1 2 分之 1
不能疊超過前面的分析
所以你就會發現
我們這個頭肩底
我們如果把上禮拜來看
我們不看左邊看右邊
那這個就是N字底
就是這邊不看的話
對
這不是N字底
我們上禮拜講的
不能疊過二分之一
第二個就是
你左邊右邊都有高點
你就把這個頸線畫一下
畫出來
這個頸線畫好了之後
這個頸線突破它就完成了
形態就確認
形態確認當然就可以做了
就可以開始做了
最強調的條件就左肩右肩
它要有一個大小
就是不能在V型反轉
要在2分之以上
然後我們來畫頸線
然後底部帶量
右肩是轉著往上走的
右肩紅k突破
突破這個頸線
也畫的頸線
好 那我們剛剛
老師其實已經拿圖出來了
那我們現在把它用圖就很容易
就明確了
非常明確
好 那我在這邊講
剛才有講下面這個頭部
不過這個先說明這不是高點的頭部
這是頭尖底的頭
它是這樣刷下來的嗎
對 不要誤會了
我們一般來說頭頭高
應該在上面嘛
那這個頭怎麼會在下面
那這個是形態
那這個形態是國外翻譯來的
是
所以先說明
好 那這個頭部頭尖底的最低點
對
那這裡有個V型反轉
那V型反轉現在做第二隻腳
這是第一隻腳嘛
第二隻腳是不是像N字底了
是
好 那為什麼這個不叫N字底
叫頭尖底
因為他還有另外一個肩膀
對 所以我們的頭尖底
在哪裡才能夠去看它
是
出現右肩你才能看
哦
如果你沒有出現右肩的話
就沒有用
是
當我右肩出來
你去看左邊
對
左邊有一個
有一個低點
而且也在1⁄之上
是
那這個就是頭尖底
哦
那如果我出現右肩往左邊看
沒有左肩
那怎麼辦
就這樣一直疊一直疊
那就是N字底
那就N字底啦
兩個都可以做
但是目標價不一樣
我們上禮拜各位複習一下
我們上禮拜N字底是從這你算的
對
這你算目標的
沒錯
那我們的投間底不是
等一下會告訴你目標價在哪
有更好嗎
當然
好
因為他的目標價會更高
那我們先知道特性
我有了右肩去看左邊
是
左邊有左肩
我就把它當作頭肩底了
頭肩底我們剛剛講這兩個高點
這個叫頸線
對 別起來
等到它一突破
這個頭肩底就完成
一般來說這三個角
大概都有一些大量
尤其是突破的地方都會有大量
因為有量才不會再疊
才會反彈
這個地方有大量的突破
突破之後它有兩個狀況
一個當然就直接到目標架了
如果它的量很大 很強
另外一個就是它因為目標價很高
幅度很大
它可能中間做一個修正在攻
這個叫回測
回測以後再漲
剛才我們也有講
回測大概有54%
大概有一半會回測
就是說你買
其實這個我們為什麼要了解這麼多
如果你在這裡買了
那你碰到回測你就不用緊張
不要太緊張
對 因為有一半會回測
你稍微報一下
他就會到目標家了
那我們為什麼要在這買
不等到回測買了
因為還有一半是直接到
如果你不買
結果這一支直接就到了
哇 你
明明就已經認出來是個頭監
對 你就後悔得要命
確沒超低
我們會買
買了以後如果有回測
你就知道我碰到那個
2分之1的
那你就報一下
報一下 然後就會到目標家
好令人安心喔
就是有一部分會直接上去
一部分其實會回測再上去
那這就是統計的
它未來的走法
大概會這樣子的情形
所以回測只要沒有破景線
不要緊張喔
我們看實力囉
好 這個就實際的股票了
那這是不是一直跌
那這邊是不是一直漲
對 漲了以後現在回來
你在這裡看到這個紅K囉
在這邊哇 紅K上來了
這裡很明顯的有一個第二個角
那第二個角我們叫右肩
這個時候我才往左邊看
左邊也沒有咧
真的有一個低點上來
但好小耶
對
那沒關係啊
這個低點沒有跌破二分之一啊
我們對你畫了二分之一啊
那我這邊的高點
跟這邊的高點
這個就畫一個景線
等到有一天突破景線
它就開始漲
那我就突破點買嘛對不對
對 你就在突破點買
所以你看這裡有回測
那回測然後你再抱一抱
再抱一抱它就到了
只要它沒有破線
或者是你按照你的均線紀律操作
或者你按你的紀律
那你就做兩趟
好不好
老師畫每次看都很簡單
沒有 這個是實際的股票
好 但是等一下如果來當空白的
我會嚇到
這是實際的股票
你看這邊是不是跌下來了
對 然後又這根紅K
是 這根紅K又漲上去了
那是不是有個右肩了
對 右肩我往左邊看
然後來找
這邊也有一個
這肩膀很小
可是很小 沒關係
肩膀大小沒關係
只要沒有跌破1分之1
都是一個好肩膀
都是好肩膀
對不對
那很標準
所以你看這一根你就發現了
哇 這個要是把頸線突破
那就成功了
所以你看第二天他就來了
他站上去了
第二天突破
然後有大量
還用跳空的
我們前幾期都有講
跳空會缺口怎麼樣
就很強勢囉
比傳播還要強
對不對
所以你要買 所以這個又成功
我們講成功的意思
這個幾乎沒有回測
長一大段才小小回測
就是成功的嘛
好像我錯過了很多
這種敵很多
真的以後你看到的話
就打電話給你
那我們來講說
周獻也一樣
要周獻啊
如果你在周獻
你做了一段時間嘛
比如說這已經長了一兩個月了
結果你去看看周獻
周縣這邊黑黑疊下來
紅黑又上來
這你也出現一個是右肩
他長這麼一大段了
我還可以用頭肩底來看
可以啊
因為你左邊有個左肩
這邊有個左肩
那你就把這邊的高點
這邊的高點化
那這一根是不是突破了
對
那一突而又長了
這幅度很大
一百長到一百四
長了
我心很大
就是他已經從這42塊
他已經長到八幾塊了
他已經長一倍了
我還可以用頭肩底
這個就叫一倍嘛
一倍理論上應該要疊了嘛
可是周限沒疊啊
周限不是又上來了嗎
所以如果用周限看
我一樣回到日線操作
你就在日線這邊突破點去做
你一樣可以做到那個目標加
所以頭肩底有長有短囉
沒錯
看我個人的喜好
其實很簡單
等於算目標加
你40長到80
那你突破是不是還可以再漲40塊
照理來說是
那不是漲到100
漲到140嘛
好吧 我就賺後面那段
那一段也不少啊
也不錯了是不是
也有四層
所以我們的進場時機怎麼攻略
我們老師幫我們
剛才看了圖 大家都想買了嘛
我每一集都讓大家都想買
看理財單就每一集都想買
可是你要知道買一點嘛
就是你不要追高也不要去
還沒有成型你就跑進去買
你不要去摸底喔
你在這邊一摸這邊又跌破了
對啊 這邊不能亂摸
一定要看到第二隻腳
第二隻腳如果出現了
這邊又有左邊的左肩
那這個看起來就是
要完成頭肩底囉
因為你已經有右肩了
又有左又有右又有微型反轉
所以等於是80%的型態都完成
只剩下最後這一步了
所以你在這裡可以去試單
因為N字底有交過試單
所以你這邊可以試單
試單像剛才那一隻
才類似第二天就過了
第二天就把全部買進來
是
你試單完了嘛
你剩下來了就在這裡買
所以我們有幾個進場點
這個叫試單點
那你在這裡試單
當然你要把停損點
要把它設好
那這個地方是第二隻腳
所以第二隻腳不能跌破
好 如果試單之後跌破了
這個點就要賣掉囉
要停損
那就頭頭低了嘛
對不對
你就走
那如果你在突破點買呢
那你就是說進場的紅K
手好停順
就等於進場這一根手好的
沒錯
那這裡有一個進場點
這裡有一個進場點
這兩個點都可以
跟N字底有點像
很像 但是目標價不一樣
為什麼
我都用N字底的方式進場了
因為它不是N字底
因為它有左肩
所以怎麼看目標價很重要囉
它的目標價是從突破點出來
喔 它要從這個點開始算
從突破的這個
一個跟景線的交叉點
然後去加多少
從你的最低點畫垂直線
跟你的景線交叉的地方
假設這邊100塊
你畫一個垂直線碰到景線
是140塊
那你這裡是不是就有40塊的價差
40塊的價差在這邊
40塊的價差
然後從這裡再加40塊
為什麼我要這樣講
因為你這兩個高點
不一定是水平的
對 他可能斜斜的
對 他可能是斜的
所以你這邊是140
斜的過來可能是136
所以你是136加40塊
所以難怪老師
你剛剛有提醒一件事
這個頭其實越大越好
因為價差會更大
目標價也會更大
那我N字底是從這算
對
那我這個手農算
哪個價位比較高
當然是這個啊
這個價位比較高啊
而且我巴不得找到一個無敵超級巨大頭
你如果這邊有漲50%這邊就再來
再漲
所以這個頭肩底的形態的目標價會比較高
你如果從這裡你做N字底你的目標價只到這
所以老師我有一個左肩是有功能的
這個左肩會讓我的目標價更高
我算目標價
我因為我做頭肩底
我沒有在做N字底
所以我的目標價會更高
OK 好
所以我這裡有講
垂直壞條線
你這邊拉一個垂直線
所以大家要特別去找囉
如果頭尖底的話
這個頭越低越好
目標越大
回去把所有圖都翻下來看
這樣就OK了嘛
這個地方到這裡
三個競場取機點
再來複習一下對不對
剛才講這邊叫試單
這個叫確認競場
還有一個點就是有回測的
如果你碰到那個回測
所以不一定有第三個點
如果沒有回測就沒有了
它就上來了
回測反而要買
對
回測不跌破反而要買
那剛才我們講在這四單
在這買
那如果有回測呢
那這邊加碼呀
加碼
對 因為它還要漲啊
如果我回測
這時候沒買的
我也可以買一點
還可以買
有空手也可以買
你已經買的可以加碼
而且這個回測再漲
這個勝率
機率大概幾乎90%
所以如果我今天買到的是沒有回頭的
那就賺你手上的
就賺你手上的
但是如果我買到有回頭
我還要開心
對 你還可以加碼
你以為我要加碼
對 其實很多
屬於比較高級討論的話
很多同學都會問
拿你加碼
其實加碼有一定的地方
像這個就可以加碼
就是很好加碼點
對 這個地方就很好的加碼點
因為你的成功率很高
對
那這樣子你就光這一波
你就獲利就很多了
因為你知道你獲利多少嗎
可以算
也可以算
OK嗎
很好 那我就可以下班去下單了
我們拉個實例看一下
還是要看實例
因為大家看圖都覺得很清楚
剛才我們講這一張圖的時候
沒有講目標價
但是現在我一樣把景線畫好
最低點是沒問題
我拉了一錘一直到5 6.34
你把這一撿
20幾塊
26塊多
如果你長56塊
你接近四成
那為什麼做一個股票有四成
OK嗎 你看
這你突破
那這邊就四單
那這你突破囉
正式進場
然後你去算一下
你一家這邊是54
因為這斜的嘛
所以這你是54
把26塊加回去
一家
80塊
ok嘛 你看這樣子你是不是就
後來就到目標
那你如果按機率走
然後你這邊回頭再買
因為他沒有疊破的低點
這邊加碼疊喔
這邊再加 然後這邊再做
那如果超過了你就多轉
因為到目標囉
可是沒有疊啊
那你就再報幾天
這個疊你就把它買了就好了
所以老師教我們一個事情
其實這邊是最低點
可是不要幻想
我們會買在最低點
因為你這時候回頭看
你如果看這個最低點
回頭看就慘了
因為我們都會幻想埋在這裡
可是事實上當我們確認他的低點的時候
其實要做一件事
趕快算喔
算可以賺多少
後面再來賺
這邊再去
這邊再進場
再進場
因為你才有把握
而且我們前面那麼多
幾個同學應該知道嘛
你要做多的
做多一定要多頭啊
那你這個又不是多頭
你怎麼做多
所以要改變我們人性的缺點
我們人性一直想抄底
事實上就是越抄越低就這個原因
你等他變成多頭
你成功的機會就很高
好
那這樣子目標也做到囉
這樣ok
好
再來看一張
現在來考一下
太快了
這張圖好棒啊
要長到八
也是長到八十幾
以前我上老師的課
每次聽完點頭如倒算
然後之後說來同學做作業囉
我不會畫
我們好久沒有遮圖了
耶 遮圖吧
很明顯底在這裡
這是微星反轉
對 等於那個大頭應該在這裡
但不一定 後面萬一跌破了
我先看一下
但總之這邊有一個V
對 這邊有個微星反轉
我就慢慢看
因為你是反彈不能做多
對 我觀察
你就慢慢等
等 等 等
你要第二隻腳嗎
我觀察繼續觀察
我繼續觀察
好久
這個紅K看起來是上來了
因為它在月線上
這個地方是不是疊下來
現在這邊是不是上來了
可是看起來好小喔
沒有關係 這邊
這個是左肩嘛
這邊是右肩嘛
現在你要畫頸線喔
頸線怎麼畫
頸線就是畫在這邊
對 你這個高點跟這個高點畫的
我們就來看一下
你這個紅K有沒有突破啊
繼續看 繼續走
如果突破就完成囉
目前看起來是有突破
突破就完成
順息就是我們真的要抓得很緊
這個地方如果突破
各位就在這裡就完成了
這個地方
對
這跟紅K加上底部大量
那你就完成
完成你就從這到這算目標價
算目標價這一段
你再從這加上去
所以我可能要看這邊是多少錢
這邊多少錢
那這邊都是黑K當然不可能做
我們一定要買紅K
那這個紅K又沒有突破嘛
對不對
所以你一定是等到突破
這一根
對
那這邊突破
然後就把停損守好
對不對
紅K的地點你把它守好
一直守守守守到這
那我們來看一下
好難
畫出來就覺得簡單多了
剛才是不是這一根
因為你沒有畫
好我們剛剛就是先用指揮棒比了一下
所以你要把線畫出來
當你線畫出來
你就這根你看有沒有量最大
剛剛我們用手指這跟事實上是站上了
對 是突破的
所以這個地方才是買進點
這個地方買進
然後我們就算目標了
趕快從這裡到這
從這可以到這
這就是目標價
所以你如果稍微抱一抱
或者你分兩次賣也可以
你在這進
然後這邊賣一次
然後回來你再買
再做第二段
大概一般大概兩段
因為這個目標有蠻高的
這邊57
這邊大概60級
不過如果趙老師的說法
他這段回測法應該要買
因為應該要買啊
對 要在這買
你要站回去均線才買
要再上來啊
再上來 再上來買
在這買 是
因為你目標還沒到
對 所以你在漲
就會到目標了
目標就會到了 好
那這樣子我們這個底部就
有的時候追蹤一支股票底
本來就不見得漲得都很漂亮
是 對不對
主力就故意給你看這樣子
哇 亂七八糟的
可是如果你把重要的高點把它劃好
那這個地方
你看你的右肩是不是很高
對不對 沒有跌下來
那整到他突破這個底就完成
其實這樣也等於是說
當我們發現一檔股票
出現一個大的V型繁殖的時候
我再來觀察他我都來得及
看有沒有右肩
我先看一下有沒有出現
下沙上來之後
再回去看有沒有左肩
如果出現右肩
回去對照左肩
看有沒有左肩
事實上我的觀察時間
就是可以相當的固定
而且我有機會抓到
對 因為這個在打底
打底我們的意思就是
要等它
對
可是你等到了
就會很大的一波的獲利
不要幻想最低點
還是要強調這件事
對
底部形態做出來
一定要做出來
就是要多頭確認
多頭確認
其實投間底為什麼容易成功
第一個它已經在月線上
因為它V型反轉
它會跑到月線上
第二個它有第二隻腳
那又突破他本來就多頭了
他已經完成多頭了
所以他就容易做到
而且剛剛朱老師有講
超底不重要啦
勝率夠高
勝率才重要
對
如果你老是超底
就算你超到一兩次
結果七八次都賠
你不可能賺錢
好
很多心法都很寶貴
所以今天呢
趙華要來告訴大家
大家都非常喜歡上
朱老師的精英班對不對
覺得太超值了
但是呢
不好意思今天播出來的話
應該是我們精英班100塊的最後一集囉
接下來對不起了
請大家全部都升等好不好
升等到我們的300元榮耀班
100塊是什麼功能呢
剩下抖內給我們理財達人秀
抖內給趙華
抖內給我們辛苦的各位達人
包括朱老師
他是一個純抖內的概念
但如果你要繼續上課的話
請大家升等300塊的榮耀班
11月11號之後
請大家通通升等好不好
另外一個還要好消息
再強調一次
我們從11月2號
禮拜一開始
理財單元秀
天天都可以看到
去哪兒看呢
如果你家還有電視的話
麻煩打開電視
我們在57台東正產星台
晚上的8點 8點檔
趙華現在是8點檔的女主角
8點到8點半
我們理財單元秀
週一到週五
都會陪著你教你
非常多的理財知識
還有非常多的新聞時事
好 那接下來
我們還是有最後一集的經營班
要告訴你什麼
隱藏版的頭肩底
有的頭肩底會騙你
其實很多的型態
還是會騙人
朱老師要更進階的教你
躲開騙人的頭肩底
好 今天的標股在現的
又教你一個
勝率超高的底部型態
就是頭肩底
學會的話
也可以賺兩次 為什麼
因為你上來突破賺一次
他回側還會再上去
所以你還有一個加碼點
套餐的概念
你可以買好買滿
當然如果沒有回測更棒了
你一次就上去了
所以頭肩底這個型態
最好合併服用上一級的N字底
兩個是相輔相成的
好 那今天的標股在線的
理財單秀就到這邊了
我們下次再見囉
Bye Bye…